-Three children, yes?
-I have three of them, yes.
-And do they know your work?
Because I would assume
that once they do,
they will enjoy it
a great deal.
-Well, I thought
I should tell them
what Dada does for a living.
-Yeah.
-I had seen --
not in terms of scale,
but I had seen Dhani Harrison
talking about his dad,
George Harrison,
that he went to school,
and for the longest time
he didn't know
that his dad was
in The Beatles.
And so people would go,
"Your dad's a Beatle."
And he would go, "Shut up!"
[ Laughter ]
And then he came home
and said to George Harrison,
"Are you a Beatle?"
And he goes,
[ As George Harrison ]
"Yeah, I am, actually."
I go,
"Why didn't you tell him?"
He goes, "I suppose I should
have, really."
[ Laughter ]
And I thought, well,
I'll tell them.
I'm not a -- a Beatle.
But, you know, I make stuff.
-Yeah.
-And so, I told him,
and we let him watch it,
and all of it went
over his head.
But he loved it.
Which I was thrilled.
In fact, we give him
an allowance and he has, like,
saving, donating,
and spending,
and he saved up
for the longest time
and he bought
an "Austin Powers" costume.
[ Laughter ]
And he does it all the time.
And I was like,
"You know, is this weird?"
He goes, "No, no,
I think it's great."
And then, we were somewhere,
and it was raining
and we were under a blanket.
And he said, "Dada,
can I tell you a secret?"
And I said, "Sure, Spike, what?"
And he goes... [whispers]
"I'm your number one fan."
[ Audience "aw"s ]
And I was like, "Oh, my God."
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-Heart --
Chest not big enough for heart.
-Yeah.
-It's just the happiest time
of my life.
These kids are fantastic,
all of them, so...
-Yeah, it's --
I agree with that.
I did not know this.
And I'm so now angry
that I wasn't there.
One performance -- you did one
performance with Fred Armisen.
-Yes.
-In a band.
-Yeah.
-Called the Modern Weepers.
-The Modern Weepers.
Yeah, we wanted to do
a mope rock band.
-Yeah.
-That sort of like --
-So like, emo-y?
Like, what would be
the inspirations?
-Like The Cure --
-Okay.
-Human League.
It's this sort of band
that's like, you know,
[ British accent ]
"You know, we're very sad
to be here tonight."
[ Laughter ]
-There's Fred.
There's Fred
and the Modern Weepers.
-You were Hugh, right?
-Yeah, that's right.
-What was your name?
-Hugh.
-Hugh. And what was your name?
-I can't remember.
-What was that --
-Do you remember
any of the songs you did?
Like, the titles?
-Yeah, yeah.
"Cry Pail."
-"Cry Pail."
-[ British accent ]
♪♪ Every time I see your face ♪♪
♪♪ I cry in a pail ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ You deliciously rejected me ♪♪
♪♪ I cry and I wail ♪♪
And the other one is "Don't Ask
Me Personal Questions."
You remember that?
-Yeah.
-"Pasta and Red Sauce."
-"Pasta and Red Sauce"?
-Yes. "Pasta and Red Sauce."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Embrace" --
-"The Girls of New York."
-Yeah.
-What's another one?
I think it was
"Catalog of Misery."
Something like that. It was --
-Yeah.
-All sad songs.
-One night only in L.A.?
-New York.
-Oh, New York.
-Mercury Lounge, yeah.
-Fantastic.
And that was it.
That was the end
of the Modern Weepers.
-Pretty much, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Well, that's the situation
where unlike George Harrison,
you might not have to
tell your son that.
-Yes. I --
-"Dad, are you a Modern Weeper?"
-"Why didn't you tell me?"
-[ Laughs ]
-"Because it's kind of
a big thing."
-Thanks so much
for being here, Mike.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
Mike Myers, everybody!